hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's time to give my
final thoughts on the demon saya
anime now as I've already addressed in
my prior video about this series I know
that I was you know very late to the
party but on the plus side I got to
binge most of it over a couple of days
which I tell you was a hell of an
experience and I have to say that I am
incredibly glad that I eventually
decided to pick this up this series very
much exceeded my expectations in almost
all areas be its story characters
animation music and the list goes on and
on and on so overall I do think the
Demon Slayer was a very schmick and
solid product with a lot of potential
for future adaptations and while I'd
like to give you photo as much credit as
possible for their work I must recognize
that the only way they were able to
elevate a series to the serval was to
start with a very good core product in
the manga which I'm going to begin
reading pretty much immediately but
without said coming at this from the
perspective of an Azov right now and it
may only watch her I'd have to say that
the characters were very much the key
feature that hooked me on this series
tandra in particular is a great
protagonist he dangles quite dangerously
on the line of being a generic shona
main character at any time that I felt
he was about to fall into mediocrity
he immediately elevated himself because
he possesses qualities that few shown in
protagonist sport and those that do for
the most part don't convey them
convincingly enough a great example of
this is that Tantra or just by being
himself has a huge impact on those
around him everyone who encounters this
boy ends up being changed in some way
whether it's becoming more driven or
coming to some sort of profound
realization and this sort of
storytelling is very very dangerous
actually
because if done incorrectly it can make
the protagonist seem incredibly
unrealistic and more of a way for the
author to insert themselves into a world
but they are always the best at
everything possible and admired by all
characters around them and my primary
example of this sort of storytelling is
always the book ready player one where
the protagonist always has the answer to
every problem and everyone around him is
just constantly high-fiving how cool and
resourceful he is demon slayer manages
to take that idea and portray it much
more convincingly by giving tandro a
hell of a lot of emotional weight and
while all those around him do come to
admire respect or at the very least
acknowledge him in some way those
feelings are well and truly earned and
generally not through a single action
either but through a series of actions
that come to endear characters to him in
fact I'd say that tandra has a very
Luffy lack quality about him he's
someone who can
versus world and constantly be capable
of winning people over not by being the
best at anything but by displaying his
unrelenting natural determination so I'm
quite drawn to him and very keen to see
how he progresses going forward the
other side of that coin though is of
course sneza Coe so I said my first
impressions video that I hadn't really
gotten to seen offered to form a proper
opinion and in general I do wish that I
had gotten to see more fur in the series
because every time she was on screen she
was a delight in some way Nezzer Co has
a wonderful mixture of adorable moments
spiced in with the same sort of
admirable determination that
characterizes her brother and that
really is the crux of the series for me
I love the idea of this partnership and
the familial bonds because you almost
never see it in a shown series in fact
family is generally the weakest element
with any parents or siblings if they
aren't dead relegated to the background
but in demons say a family is the
selling point and despite the fact that
most of Tonto his family are dead they
play an incredibly relevant role in the
journey going forward like I mentioned
in my episode 19 video I love the fact
that the only plausible way that they
were able to overcome rui was the idea
of the power of familial bonds tandra
inherits an upgrade from their father
and Nezzer Co was prompted by their
mother and only together as a family
unit were they able to get the better of
rui although I am still glad that they
weren't able to defeat him for good
because I do think the series has some
potential power scaling issues in fact
something that makes me very nervous is
the fact that every new encounter with a
demon seems to make gigantic loops of
power instead of presenting a more
gradual increase I mean starting from
the very beginning humans are completely
outclassed by one standard demon who is
completely outclassed by a Big Boi demon
there was nothing compared to the fake
12 Kazuki who are nothing compared to
spider daddy who is absolutely nothing
compared to Rui it was assumedly
absolutely nothing compared to the
super-powered lower moon dude bro who is
assumedly absolutely nothing compared to
the upper moons who are assumedly
absolutely nothing compared to the King
of Pop it's a very minor issue but
something that has the potential to get
out of control very quickly there isn't
a lot of middle ground and in a lot of
cases the current villain seems to
possess completely godlike power
compared to the previous and as a result
it requires a better and better
explanation as to how we are eventually
able to defeat them which has already
begun to demand blatant power-ups but to
the credit of the series it has been
handled exceptionally well so far but it
does make me a little nervous for the
future moving back to characters though
much enjoyed the eventual extended cast
that were introduced for the most part
that is I mean starting when sending to
this boy has me really conflicted I both
love and cannot stand him in equal
measure on the one hand he's easy to
empathize with because he's one of the
more regular human characters in the
series being thrust into situations that
he is clearly not mentally prepared for
we've all been there but at the same
time calm yo farm his gags are genuinely
funny for the first couple of times but
the problem is especially in the first
few episodes he was in he just never
stops he screams and screams and screams
and screams and screams and then takes a
break to yell but after that he screams
and screams and screams and then he'll
do something cool and to be fair when he
is in actions any to is an absolute
highlight of the series I loved the idea
that he can only perform one technique
and the whole concept of just mastering
one thing in general and it just looks
so spectacular
every time he performs it also he has a
lot of decent dramatic substance in his
backstory and his struggle to get
through life but my god do we have to
sift through a lot of screaming and
being a general pervert to get there his
sustained energy is just a bit too much
for me although to be fair this did get
better over the course of the series and
I feel like he ended up as a much more
balanced character by the end then
there's also in ask and I thought I was
going to have the same problem with him
at first because for an episode or two
all he did was yell and yell about
wanting to fight but he got over that
really quickly and became a truly great
and enjoyable character he's good
all-rounder really is he can do some
great comedy some phenomenal action with
his amazing self-taught breathing and he
has a really super solid character
design always a feast for the eyes and a
charm for the mind and of course most of
the tertiary cast also falls into that
category there were very few characters
who were introduced in demon slayer that
I just plain did not like and actually I
can't think of any off the top of my
head they may have been characters I
felt indifferent about like some of the
more generic demons but otherwise it was
an incredible cost of individuals
because even those who got such small
amounts of screen time had a decent
impact on me and I think this is
especially true of the large majority of
demons actually one of the greatest
assets demon saya has is the
humanization of these figis who in more
typical stories would generally be cast
as evil for the sake of evil but I love
that these creatures who have done truly
horrifying things many of which was in
front of our very eyes can still gun a
sympathy from the human struggles and
moments of realization it generates a
genuine connection between the
antagonists of the series and the viewer
which is such a difficult bond to
achieve and in most cases I feel the JIT
iment loss when these demons do meet
their final demise
it makes me quite excited to move on and
see further demons because it would seem
that the more powerful the fur the more
tragic a pass they have which I imagine
will eventually culminate in Kabuto G
and in that quest as I've already stated
I will be pursuing the manga because I
can't stand the idea of waiting God
knows how long for another season and
that is a great credit to the anime
adaptation as well as the original
product for coming together to
completely hook me but while we're on
this episode 26 had some good and some
bad news the good news being that a
demon say a film has been greenlit
picking up right where we left off this
sounds fantastic
cannot wait however the bad news is that
Demon Slayer film was given the
greenlight
which means that the second series is
but a faraway dream at the moment and
while that's a shame I'm not really sure
what more I could ask for really we've
been given 26 episodes of a brilliant
world well performed characters and some
nice little twists on what could have
very easily been another generic shown
in battle series my favourite twist of
which actually is the power system which
seems based almost entirely upon
breathing it's such a wonderful
representation of what focus and correct
technique can do to add potency impact
and mastery over a martial art it's not
an easy system to sell though and I
actually imagine that the manga has a
much more difficult time with this idea
but as a result of that difficulty it is
able to hit that much harder it's not as
simple as a magical powers acquiring a
quirk building and molding energy or
even consuming a devil fruit it's much
more basic than that and yet infinitely
more complicated and I just love the
idea that in theory any human in this
world could learn the techniques we see
on display in the series purely through
mastery of breath it's not restrictive
however as a result it accepts only the
very best with brutal consequences for
those deemed unworthy so it is a pure
triumph in that regard however with that
said demon sight does occasionally fall
into some Shonen traps one of which
occurred right at the tail end of the
anime when all of the hashira were
introduced together now some people may
not consider this a trap but in my
experience it's never a great idea to
introduce a large group of profound
characters all at once firstly because
the bombardment of characters lost a
great condensed experience for the
viewer or reader at the time doesn't
really allow for individuals to get the
attention they most certainly deserve
given their position and secondly
because it removes a huge layer of
intrigue going forward in the series so
for example I really loved when I only
knew of the existence of - huh sure
not knowing how many of them existed nor
what sort of crazy powers or designs
they inhabited gave a nice air of
mystery and made me want to explore this
bolt infinitely to discover all of them
so it was slightly disappointing to have
them all dumped on me all at once but
this is such a minor complaint as is
every negative aspect I've brought up in
this review none of the things I've
mentioned are series Breaking and for a
lot of people this might even be another
selling feature a ton of people might
love Zenit to stupidly high energy as
well as being embodied by high-level
characters and that's great it's just
not my personal preference but even with
those things in mind there is no way
that I can come away from this anime
with anything less than a glowing
recommendation I'm thrilled to have been
on board with this journey even if I did
jump on a fair bit light so as a result
it's been a fairly intense and condensed
experience but something that has
reminded me of why I loved the anime
medium and that pretty much does it for
my final thoughts on demon slayer if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produced in general and please
do consider donating to the new ultra
view patreon because the support of all
of your amazing people is what continues
to make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps spot
this channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun and anytime
and please do head over to my discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
reign takes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your
thoughts on Demon Slayer this has been
the new volt review and I'll see you
next time
[Music]